you sell your soul to the devil because
you want to know the truth but maybe
maybe the truth is less important in
some abstract factual sense and
ontological reality is less important
than like you said kind of leading from
the heart or or leading a true honest
life in accordance with virtues that for
all we know say there is some higher
trans temporal alien realm it maybe
maybe that's the currency and maybe our
sort of you know capitalist construct or
you know where we sort of we barter for
thing you know we we we have currency
that's fungible and then and and and you
know we we have limited real estate and
you know and we have possessions maybe
maybe maybe currency maybe the currency
up there is actually love and you know
the four virtues or something